what's happened in the Baltic shows just
how vulnerable Britain's own network of
offshore pipes and cables could be to a
hostile Nation North Sea drilling
platforms are linked together by a
network of pipelines which then feed
into larger arteries that come ashore in
Shetland orkney and the mainland Britain
also Imports gas from Norway through a
pipeline laid up to 360 meters below the
waves it can carry a fifth of the UK's
Peak gas demand and there are gas
pipelines linking the UK with Belgium
and the Netherlands too each with a
similar capacity the dash for green
electricity has resulted in vast wind
farms taking root in the shallow Waters
around our Coast there are now more than
two and a half thousand turbines
generating 12.7 gigawatts of electricity
that's the equivalent of four nuclear
power stations and all that comes ashore
in cables laid along the bottom of the
North Sea there are interconnectors too
marked here in yellow those are cables
that link the electricity Grid in the UK
with France Belgium the Netherlands
Norway and Ireland together they have a
capacity of just under seven and a half
gigawatts now Communications cables for
phone calls and the internet they're
marked in Gray they also connect the UK
with the rest of Europe as well as the
United States and Canada and they are
critical for the economy so how secure
is our undersea infrastructure well
communication cables are just thicker
than a garden hose and although they
have a steel sheath even a shark can
bite them in two undersea electricity
cables are a little Slimmer than your
thigh and have several layers of metal
and plastic armor but they can be
severed by a ship dragging its anchor
and gas pipelines are stronger the one
to Norway is more than a meter across
with three and a half centimeter thick
steel walls that are then encased in
concrete but it's not designed to resist
an explosion our best protection is the
large number of cables and pipes coming
ashore if one is severed internet
connections and electricity can be
re-routed the head of the UK's Armed
Forces warned early this year of
increased activity by Russian submarines
around the UK and said any attempt to
damage cables would be considered an act
of War